- [Voiceover] Given the polynomial above,
what are its zeros?
So the zeros of this polynomial
are going to be the x-values
that make it equal to zero.
So it's going to be the x-values
that make this expression equal to zero.
Or you could say the x-values
that satisfy this equation.
Because if you satisfy this equation,
you're making this
expression equal to zero.
So what are those x-values going to be?
Well, if I take the product of two things,
and if they're going to be equal to zero,
I can get zero if one or both
of these are equal to zero,
'cause zero times anything is zero.
So x plus seven
could be equal to zero,
or another way to solve this
is for x minus 10 to be equal to zero.
So the zeros here,
well how do we get x plus
seven to be equal to zero?
Well, subtract seven from both sides.
X could be negative seven.
And if I add 10 to both sides here,
x could be equal to 10.
Either of these is going to make
this expression equal to zero.
You can see that.
If x is equal to negative seven,
this is going to be zero.
Zero times anything here,
the whole thing's gonna be zero.
If x is going to be equal to 10,
this expression's going to be zero.
And then the whole thing's gonna be zero.
So x is equal to negative seven,
and x is equal to 10,
which is that choice.
I wasn't able to circle in on
that choice right over there.
X equals negative seven,
and x is equal to 10.